le modèle les demoiselles
mesdemoiselles vous voilà arrivés à la
fin de votre dernière année d'études
dans notre chère institutions
d'éducation sexuelle
vous êtes actuellement de grandes jeune
fille oui vous êtes de grande jeune
fille maintenant et vous devez savoir
que les enfants arrivent à cheval si
j'ose dire sur les cigognes et qu'elles
viennent remplir nos cheminées de petits
enfants tout rose enroulés dans leur
l'ange au milieu du bec de la fameuse
cigognes précédemment cités maintenant
comment procède t exactement le papa et
la maman est bien le soir lorsqu'ils
sont dans la chambre à coucher
le papa baisse la lumière et sort son
catalogue
alors là à savon voilà le papa et la
maman commente un petit frère ou une
petite soeur par la poste
et puisque vous ne devez pas ignorer
ceux ci en ce dernier jour comment
recoller reconnaît-on les petits garçons
des petites filles
je sais je sais allez bien au rugby
oui j'oubliais c'est très simple
soulever les draps et leur à ce moment
là on peut simplement distinguer que les
petites filles ont des layettes rose et
les petits garçons des layettes bleus